all right we are now live for session
seven of understanding anger 2.0 so
while people are gathering and uh
streaming in I'll just give you a little
summary of what this uh series is some
people might want to call it a class but
it's more of a monthly series of me
giving some information and everybody
else getting to use the chat function to
chime in ask questions raise issues all
of that and of course you know the as
the title indicates understanding anger
is the goal of this and we did this as a
series face Toof face at you know years
and years ago I want to say
2014 no
2015 at the Kingston public library in
New York in the Hudson Valley and I you
know I started teaching a class last uh
Academic Year specifically focused on
anger at Marquette University and so a
lot of people were like hey maybe you
should restart that series and I gave it
some thought and I said yeah okay we
could do this online reach a much wider
audience and I could do as many of these
as I would like to or as many as the
audience would potentially be interested
in so we kicked it off earlier this year
and we'll be continuing on with uh
future Years and we're doing ancient
philosophy and literature this year
we'll probably stick to that for next
year although we may go a little bit
further along in in the history maybe
we'll get into some early medieval we'll
see and so this session is devoted to
Aristotle who is really one of the first
Western thinkers to systematically think
about and analyze the emotion of anger
last session we looked at a very
important work of Aristotle with respect
to the emotions uh the art of rhetoric
book two is devoted entirely to
discussion of the emotions and how they
play out and why because it's very
important for somebody who wants to be
persuasive to understand how the
emotions work how to provoke them how to
lessen them so that was all drawing from
the rhetoric today we're going to be
looking at some other texts uh primarily
the Nic mccan and yudaman ethics bit of
the politics we might uh touch on some
other ones as well but you we can only
pack in so much
so um let's Jump Right In um you know
Aristotle is very interested in Anger he
talks about it in a lot of different
texts ranging from the two ethics to on
the soul or the day Ona the politics the
parts of animals even uh seemingly
logical works like on sophistic
reputations and the topics just to give
you an example in un sophistical
reputations he talks about the technique
of getting your uh interlocutor angry so
they'll make dumb mistakes you know um
now that's not you could say a
systematic treatment it's just a oneoff
sort of thing and Aristotle doesn't
write one single systematic treaties on
anger as some later authors will do we
do know interestingly that there was an
Aristotelian somewhere down the line
whose name was Jerome or her heronimus
and he wrote a text on Anger from an
Aristotelian perspective it's
unfortunately lost as so many ancient
texts are to Antiquity but then we see
people like senica or Plutarch you know
writing treates on anger later on from
you know stoic or or PL platonist
perspectives and they engage Aristotle
very very heavily so they're you know
it's clear that there was an
Aristotelian approach to anger and so
what we have to do is kind of piece it
together from the various works and I
want to begin with a passage from the
deona or on the soul so Aristotle is
using this as an
example talking about how we take
multiple perspectives on different
phenomena in you know moral life or
psychology or what whatever we want to
call it and he talks about anger and how
how would we understand anger how what
sort of perspective do we approach it
from and he says well we're going to
understand it differently depending on
what we are doing what discipline we're
working in so he uses just two examples
there a physicist somebody who's
interested in bodies who might be
interested in medicine or things like
that will think about anger in those
physical bodily terms as now here was
the sort of popular view at the time as
a boiling of blood around the heart
right anger was associated with certain
organs the heart uh was the the thing
that some people thought did the
thinking and feeling um the liver with
that generates uh bile was also
important for it and that's one
perspective right we can think about
anger in physiological terms and there
are people who do that today and then he
talks about a dialectical philosopher
dialectics right which would mean
somebody who is interested not so much
in the body but in thought and in
emotions or in our our reasoning
processes they're going to view anger as
a desire to make another person suffer
in return now are these incompatible
with each other no there are two
different ways of looking at the same
overarching phenomenon and in my own
research on Aristotle on anger which
goes back all the way to graduate school
so we're talking about two decades I
actually come to the pre preliminary
conclusion that there are at least six
different ways in which Aristotle is
looking at anger in his various works so
one of these is um what I call the
psychic or somat physical or somatic
right anger as a matter of the study of
physics the the you know changing
environment of physical
bodies um includes biology and so we get
a lot of discussion in various Works in
terms of motion the heart the blood
warmth all that kind of stuff and that's
his you know it's interesting from a
historical perspective it doesn't map on
to our conception of the body at present
or what we know about animals as well at
the at the present time so I I don't
really do too much with that there are
other people who are quite interested in
like the parts of animals and the
history of animals and things like that
then we get what we've already discussed
the emotional or psychological right
what we get from the rhetoric and a few
other places as well anger is one of the
basic human emotions and we want to know
how it works what provokes anger what
lessons it how to distinguish Anger from
other emotions like say hatred or
righteous indignation and we talked
about that last time so we're going to
put those two aside we're more
interested did in these four other
dimensions one of them is what I call
ethical or protic so prasis is
Aristotle's term for our faculty that
does the choosing and where our
character winds up being based so you
know whether we're virtuous or vicious
with respect to anger and we're going to
talk a lot about that today um you know
we want to think about how our
emotional uh responses and actions
coming from how choices our motivations
how these fit together how we can
evaluate them as good or bad um so
that's a very important Dimension that
we're going to look at shortly and then
there's another I call volitional or
practically rational how does anger
feeling anger being motivated by anger
how does it affect choice or reasoning
or deliberation or the intellectual
virtue of prudence or the phenomenon
that we're going to disc discuss uh
later on in this of what we call a CIA
that's a Greek word and we translate it
sometimes in a very old-fashioned way as
incontinence or weakness of will but a
better translation is really lack or
loss of self-control how does anger
figure into that so that's a a fourth
dimension then we can talk about you
know political or legal aspects that's
another dimension um how does anger
figure
into uh political events or
conflicts um how does it affect
legislation um what sort of legal
responsibility for doing wrong does
anger you know provide or excuse these
are all questions that figure in and and
you know Aristotle discusses these to
some degree in the rhetoric and the the
two ethics but especially in the
politics so that's that's a work we're
going to look at today and then the
final Dimension the sixth one is what I
call the responsive or thic and this is
from thin or thoy which means uh you
know to feel confident to feel uh able
to do things anger is a very active
emotion and you know Aristotle says that
one pseudo form of courage is actually
thumos or getting angry it's it's a
respon response we have to perceived
threats um so it has to do with
confidence and fear and it also has to
do with temperament we're going to see
that Aristotle endorses in the politics
a kind of Goldilocks thing with respect
to the Greeks they have the right amount
of thumos not like those laxidasical
Egyptians and Phoenicians that are kind
of lacking in it or those you know crazy
Northern people who have too much of it
you know the Greeks are just right so
we're gonna talk about that in a bit now
all of these I
think provide us with some
intelligibility a capacity to
understand um you know Human Action and
emotion and characters and decisions
even legal or political matters and they
all kind of interpenetrate each other so
it's not they're not like sealed off
boxes where we go from oh we're you know
we're no longer here in the
psychological we're now here in the
ethical and they don't have anything to
do with each other they actually have a
lot to do with each other at least in
Aristotle's point of view and so we're
going to be looking at these four uh
main Dimensions some a bit more than
others and I also do want to point
something out before we jump right in um
you know we've talked in previous
sessions about the Greek vocabulary for
anger
Aristotle typically is using two main
words one is or which we've encountered
already with you know
Plato and uh to to some extent with
hessed and Homer another is thumos which
is also very important you remember in
Plato thumos was the part of your soul
that gets angry right for Aristotle it's
not quite like that he doesn't have the
same psychology that that Plato does and
Aristotle often uses these uh
synonymously so um you know in the
rhetoric there's this
phrase right thumos and or are being
used just as as as if they're the same
thing um you know in the Udan ethics he
says that courage
isum courage courage can sometimes arise
through anger and uh IRAs ability or
whatever we want to call thumos right
and then there's other um words that get
used there's verbs or Z from
or
Thum anagain is a common one halan which
means to be you know irritable to be uh
a pain in in the butt uh
par so the par you know is is the sort
of sharpness that comes with it there's
a bunch of adjectives as well and then
there's also a vocabulary of anger's
opposite of calmness prow is the the
word that we use for the gentle or mild
or you know um right tempered person
Pras is the the uh noun that we use for
The Virtue as well as the lack of of
anger
sunos these are words for forgiveness or
letting something go Aristotle actually
uses a term that we see in uh the
gospels um where forgiveness is usually
framed in terms of a literally to let
something fly to let something go
Aristotle actually uses that in rhetoric
book book one as well so there's an
interesting vocabulary there that we can
go into if people are interested in that
uh but let's talk about the ethics now
so this this dimension of the ethical or
the protic how we how we are as people
morally there's this really famous nican
ethics passage that I think everybody is
familiar with and interestingly enough
is the very first passage in Daniel
Goldman's uh you know classic book
emotional
intelligence and it's it's in Nicol
mccan ethics early on anybody can become
angry but to be angry at the right time
and for the right purpose is not within
everybody's
power we can all get it angry we all
have the capacity for it but getting
things right is a lot
tougher um so you know if you know
Aristotle and you know his ethics you
know that the middle position or the
mean is quite important so the right
amount getting angry to the right degree
right but there's a whole bunch of other
rights or uh he calls them difficulties
at one point you know uh how you're
angry topos in in Greek you know the way
in which you express your anger the
people with whom you are angry on what
grounds epip in in Greek how long right
do you get angry and it goes away right
away or you you say a few things and now
you're not angry or do you hold a grudge
forever um up to one point one is right
or makes a mistake in being it angry is
something that he talks about and he
says that we can go wrong in a whole
bunch of different ways we can get wrong
we can get angry with the wrong people
this is a very common uh experience
you've all been on the end of somebody
else venting or attacking uh somebody
because they're ticked off but you're
not the person who ticked them off right
you're the wrong person uh or you've
done this yourself right you your boss
yells at you you come home and you you
yell at somebody else or you get on the
internet and and you know uh act out of
anger um getting angry for the wrong
reasons this happens quite frequently
more than you should Malon a day also
more quickly how how much does it take
to get you mad at at people right this
is a a key thing or for a longer time
and so you know for Aristotle all of
these factor into what he calls the mean
or the middle position position we
should remind ourselves of one uh other
thing as well um Aristotle says that to
have a virtue a good state of character
is not just to act in accordance with
reason logos and Prudence fris but to
act as The Virtuous person does so
there's kind of an aspect of modeling
this could be intergenerational or
cultural right and that that can be very
powerful for good uh that can also be a
problem right if we have the wrong kinds
of models we might get things wrong
without even realizing it in the nican
ethics um Aristotle suggests that
there's not too many people who don't
get angry as they ought to that the
vices are on really the side of excess
in the emian ethics it's a little bit
more balanced and I I think myself that
this is probably a reflection of
Aristotle writing for not the entirety
of Greek culture or even Athenian
culture but primarily for uh welltoo you
know um able to participate in politics
because they're citizen men who you know
um have a lot lot more power than
everybody else in society so they don't
have to stuff their anger down quite as
often and they might actually be
expected to like act on anger because
that's viewed as being manly but I think
we can extend this to just about
everybody uh in his own time and in the
present so um the vocabulary that's
important here we already brought up a
little bit of it the virtue is what he
calls Pras and this is a term that gets
used um quite a lot in ancient Greek uh
going on through the centuries after
Aristotle The Virtuous person is called
prow which we transl it is mild or
gentle or of good temper interestingly
in some other literature pra is
translated as Meek and I'll just give
you one example of that in the
Septuagint the Greek translation of the
Hebrew texts of the Old Testament and
the other texts that are written in
Greek like the wisdom of Solomon and Ben
sarak and stuff like that um Moses is
called prow Moses is called Meek now if
you know thing about the the guy Moses
as he's depicted in the stories he he
kills an Egyptian he gets angry you know
uh he he uh breaks the tablets when he
sees the people screwing up he's not a
guy who doesn't ever get angry but he's
considered to be prow he's considered to
they're not using an Aristotelian
conception but this is a broader
cultural idea so uh let's talk about um
going wrong with anger and then maybe
we'll do a little bit of Q&A for take a
little pause and and uh we'll come back
to this so excess right you know if
you've got a mean that's a middle
position you got the too much you got
the too little over here Aristotle
actually distinguishes not just one Vice
of excess but he talks about five of
them four of them in the nicoman ethics
and then the yudaman ethics adds one
more to this now is this an entire
typology of ways people get anger wrong
no we could have others besides this as
well so there's the quick temper or the
hotheads we might translate them the
oroy in Greek they get angrier quicker
than they ought to with the wrong people
over the wrong things but there's one
nice thing about them their anger is
quickly dissipated so they get angry
quickly but they also get non angry or
calm Qui quickly as well um it's still a
problem right they're getting things
wrong characteristically they fly off
the handle as we say uh you know it's a
common expression in the uh yudaman
ethics and in the rhetoric Aristotle
uses a different term U thumos and this
means like sharp tempered right think of
them as like always ready to go off and
I've known people like this I actually
kind of Envy them as somebody who's had
a struggle with anger because they are
vicious but it's not as bad as some of
the other
vices so a vice that's worse is the
rageful the acolo so holos is bile the
bile that's produced by your liver this
is a a term that gets used in ancient
literature uh going way before aristot
like in Homer for for anger right and um
they get angry quickly but they get
angry over everything and they're not
like the short fused people the hotheads
in that they don't they don't cease
being angry uh right away right so they
they tend to get angry in all sorts of
situations these are the people that um
we say you've got an anger problem right
then there's a a third one and um the
word perroy that Aristotle uses to
describe them literally means bitter
right the taste of bitterness as opposed
to sweetness glucose right um or other
tastes and interestingly the Greeks
arranged um the the eight tastes or the
nine or seven different flavor profiles
they didn't have four as we often talk
about in the present um they arranged
them with sweet on one end and then like
fatty came close to that and then bitter
on the other end and so bitterness is
something B
right and Aristotle um says that these
are people who remain angry for a long
time they keep their anger in they hold
on to it they guard it right and they
remain resentful um they're motivated by
Vengeance and these people are discussed
in the nicam ethics in the rhetoric and
in the ud Damian ethics in the ud Damian
ethics they literally guard their anger
they they maintain a watch on it and so
these are people that are pretty hard to
get out of the state of anger and then
we have another one uh which is kind of
curious they the theal you remember I I
use the term kalain right so the Halo
are we translate them as harsh tempered
or Troublesome I actually like the
translation pains in the asses you know
the kind of people that are always kind
of you know sniping passive aggressive
irrit
you know and they uh like he says become
Troublesome in in classic Greek and that
means to like you know raise raise
trouble with with other people and they
do so more than they should for a longer
time and then he says they will not be
reconciled without retribution you know
which is what anger seeks or punishment
Colossus you know hurting the other
person um in the Udan he calls these the
Tho tho Odes and then in the adamian
ethics we have one other class and this
is less to do about how intense the
anger is or how long you hold on to it
has to do more with behavior like the
people who get really out of
control um they are the violent The plag
Taste the people who hit other people
literally or the abusive the uh loros
that that means people people who use
bad language who call people names who
you know say things who tear other
people down they're engaging in
retaliation which is what anger is is
looking for right and um this uh
Aristotle thinks it can be understood as
a separate Vice you know it's not just
that they feel too much anger they're
too easy in using force or um insult
against other people so those are the
the five vices specific vices with
respect to anger but we could have
others as as well then we've got you
know on the other side vices of defect
not getting angry when you should get
angry when it's appropriate and he calls
them a couple different words he calls
them inerasable or spiritless on oron
right so an is is without and then the
or is is anger right so these are the
people who don't get angry or even
slavish uh androp androd does in in h
Aristotle's Greek so these are the
people who are willing to put up with
things that they shouldn't he says they
don't get angry at things that they
ought to get angry or in situations
where they ought to um they're
considered foolish they don't get angry
with the right people at the right time
in the right way
um so who should you get angry with we
could ask right if uh so one of the
examples that I use quite frequently in
discussing this is when you have
somebody who you are responsible for and
you see them getting bullied well you
from an Arista tillan perspective you
should get angry not like you know get
angry and pick up a hammer and start
beating people on the head but you
should get angry enough to motivate you
to do the right thing which is to stand
up for the people who are you know
perhaps your your spouse your children
your parents these are people Aristotle
talks about in in the
rhetoric and they will uh these people
who are vicious by not getting angry
they accept insults and humiliating
treatment they don't stand up for
themselves or their friends um in the
emian ethics he says they feel pain
slowly or less intensely or for a short
time and Aristotle says sometimes this
gets praised as mildness as the ver
but it's not really it's it's vicious so
that's a lot of me talking already we're
about half an hour into this any
questions comments people want to raise
before we start talking about the
virtue of uh good temper and um how we
can figure out how to how to deal how to
do this you
know take a little
drink meanwhile also say hi to uh people
that are saying hello uh Mark and the
White
Tower um Mark is a longtime interloc the
White Tower is a a newer one um if there
aren't any questions I'll I'll move on
and talk about um The Virtue with
respect to
anger give it just another few
seconds
all right well let's let's launch into
it then so what is the virtue like you
know again we mentioned for Aristotle oh
here we go uh well the sellin we'll
we'll address later on because that's
more of a political question
um and the white tyus says how could you
best stand up for your friends
especially if they you're bullied at
school well this is the lead into the
virtue then let's so um we should talk
about what Aristotle thinks right anger
looks like so Aristotle says um there
aren't any universal rules for this
right we have to be attentive to the
what he calls the particulars or the
context he says that uh judgment uh Cris
occurs through perception of you know
what's what's in the
situation and you know one way of
looking at this is these rights how do
we apply these the right this the right
that that gets us to the meeting so
right person who should we be angry with
so you know just to take um uh the white
towers question standing up for your
friends being bullied at school um the
right person to direct your anger at is
the bully or the school officials who
are not doing something about it you
could go into the principal's office and
be ticked off and be like you're not
doing something about bullying right um
taking it out on random people wrong
person right so we want to be directing
our anger at the people who are
responsible for the situation right
grounds or Reason um it's very important
that the for for The Virtuous anger that
you're getting angry over the right
things and for the right reason um not
because you know so again bullying um if
you want to think about your your
dependent being bullied um you could
have a wrong reason for getting angry
you could be like I can't believe they
did that to me they didn't do it to you
they did it to your kid right and you
should be concerned about your kid as a
person who matters not just as an
extension of yourself right so the right
reason uh the right manner or way this
has to do more with how we express our
anger how we act on it um again if if we
use the example of bullying you see
somebody getting bullied you you get
angry what do you do you could say hey
now that off or hey don't be a bully
right now you could also go and pick up
a 2x4 and start beating the crap out of
them that would be excessive right um
now if the bullies start attacking you
maybe then it's time to pick up a 2x4
and start hitting them but you there's a
lot of ways in which when we get angry
uh we don't have to go quite so far at
the very start uh the right intensity of
emotion how angry do we get there's some
things for which it's you know it's more
appropriate for us to get mildly annoyed
there's other things where it does make
sense for us to get really angry right
and then everything in
between um there's some people who just
get really angry over every single thing
like the rageful who we talked about
earlier right that is a vicious
disposition um the you could say there's
a
proportionality to um your your anger if
you're virtuous you get angry to the
right amount um right quickness how
quickly do you get angry do you get
angry over let's say you're
driving and you know traffic is slow do
you get angry right away does it take
you quite a long time before it bothers
you do maybe you don't get bothered at
all because you're like well nothing
nothing I can do about traffic right so
the the
rapidity with which you get angry how
long you stay angry you know The
Virtuous person is not going to hold on
to their anger forever because that's
not good it'll actually congeal into
something more like hatred after a while
um how you retaliate or how you act are
you acting rightly or are you making an
error or or sin and then you know
another possibility for The Virtue um
that Aristotle actually talks about that
it sounds less like a the right amount
of emotion and more like the stoic
approach that that senica will lay out
later on is to be untroubled or
calm
umos not driven by the emotion but as
reason ordains right senica will observe
later on we're going to talk about this
uh I think in December that uh anything
that you can do with the emotion of
anger you can also do with right
practical
reason and Aristotle brings it to a
close by saying The Virtuous person is
not really disposed to punish but to
forgive so they're not going to get
angry in every single situation they'll
get angry when it's appropriate to the
right amount with the right people you
know all all of these sorts of of things
and um one of the things that we can
think about I think this is quite
helpful how do we actually get there
right so we generally for virtues for
Aristotle we have a pro we don't we
don't automatically have the virtue we
get there by a process of moving uh
through being self-controlled through
doing things that we recognize is right
but we don't really want to you know
like like we restrain our anger to
actually being
virtuous and you know anger he thinks
serves an important role it provides
energy or motivation that can be
integrated and this is the key thing
integrated not anger is not running the
show it's it's a tool and anger can also
serve another helpful role um sometimes
being angry will help us attend to
things that we were missing before to
particulars to modalities of moral
values to what Nancy Sherman calls
ethical salience you know what is
relevant in the
situation um
and so you know how do we form ourselves
as people this is something that is a
bit underemphasized in Aristotle's
account um the laws you know it's common
in ancient philosophy to talk about the
laws uh helping us out I don't think our
laws really do at all um they don't make
us virtuous they're sort of like
guardrails you can go this far but not
any further um praise and blame this is
very important for
Aristotle um you know we learn early on
if we have good guardians or good
advisors we get praised for doing the
right thing we get we get criticized or
blamed for doing the wrong thing we can
also say that um culture plays a role
examples what Aristotle calls mimesis um
which is uh imitation which includes all
of our cultural products you know when
we see something on TV and we then
follow that example that is is mimesis
and he talks about that quite a bit in
in the Poetics and the politics
um education and discipline um we don't
get an awful lot of this when it comes
to anger in our contemporary societies
we don't get much explicit discussion of
how the emotions work uh unless you
screw up and then they send you to anger
management and then you start to learn
about this sort of thing um you know we
could also talk about um what we're
doing right here explicit reasoning
about anger how it does things you know
having dialogues doing doing some
counseling or philosophy and Aristotle
unfortunately doesn't give
us exercises for dealing with anger like
um later philosophers will like Sena
again for example or Plutarch but it
doesn't mean that we couldn't actually
derive these ourselves and I think that
there's U that's kind of a good project
for people to work on you know we figure
figuring out what the mean is asking all
these questions when I'm in a situation
and I'm starting to get ticked off and
I'm ready to like blow up at this person
is this the right person or am I going
the wrong way with my anger I'm tempted
to like I'm so angry I want to punch
somebody or say something you know start
swearing at people is that the right way
of expressing my anger um we can also
look at as we're going to talk about our
perceptions and judgments and reasoning
processes because those play a role
anger is not just a knee-jerk
response Aristotle thinks as does Plato
as do the stoics that emotions have both
an affective side A Feeling side but
they're also cognitive they are the
result of making judgments of engaging
in you know reasoning processes thought
processes as as we call them and you can
look at that and you can examine your
thought processes
and figure out where you're going wrong
and how to fix
that so um let's talk uh
about
the next Dimension the volitional or
practically rational Dimension and this
is where we bring up this term that I I
mentioned at the start of this acrosia
which you know it gets translated in
older translations as incontinence uh
kind of uh has the wrong connotations
these days um weakness of will Aristotle
doesn't actually have a conception of
will as such so that's not that great of
a translation or lack or loss of
self-control I think that's a better
translation and this is a really major
contribution that Aristotle makes to
moral theory making sense of a
experience that we clearly have you know
um when we know what the right thing is
and we do the opposite or we know
something is wrong and that we shouldn't
do it and yet we do do it right there's
knowledge and there's a failure to
follow through on that knowledge and uh
Richard Robinson has a really great quip
about this in his article Aristotle on
acrosia he says he did evidently he did
not write nearly a whole book on acrosia
to deny that it ever occurs there are
some philosophers you know certain
interpretations of Socrates um the stoic
sometimes although they're a bit of two
minds about this where they say there's
no such thing as AIA Aristotle says yeah
there is and I'm G to tell you about it
so you know um Aristotle is going to
give us kind of a fragmentary outline
sketch of this and uh interestingly we
tend to be rather you know actic or we
don't have automatic self-control it's
something we have to develop
over time uh miles berni the great uh
classic scholar said the seeds of
acrosia are going to be with us as soon
as we enter Aristotle's lecture room we
we are trying to develop right and so
acrosia occurs According to Aristotle
because we have a conflict within us
between something higher and something
lower and what what the higher and the
lower is varies considerably it could be
you know right principle could be um you
know fasis it could be um you know basis
which is a sort of the the rational
appetite and then what we're uh failing
in respect to it could be desire it
could be the emotions it could be all
sorts of things right um could be uh
desire for for physical pleasure uh or
to avoid pain but what happens is we've
got a kind of uh disharmony within the
soul and then we follow the dictates of
of the lower part and Aristotle tells us
that there's different kinds of accia
there's like accia per se which we're
not going to talk about here that has
more to do with pleasure right and pain
and then there's we can be acatic with
respect to all sorts of other things so
some of these are Goods like parents and
children you know people will do the
wrong thing because they they want to
maintain that relationship they want to
help out their kids they want to help
out their their family right wealth
people do all sorts of things that they
shouldn't um that they know they
shouldn't because they want to make
money or hold on to money but it can
also occur with respect to anger we lose
our self- control and we say things do
things that we know we shouldn't and yet
we find ourselves doing them right I
think it's a very common experience
isn't it and so he says that um we can
distinguish it as a AIA Catos a
qualified form of
accia uh in relation to the pleasures
and pains that are provoking or involved
in the emotion of anger um the desire
that anger
involves um you know these are things
that we see in the rhetoric discussion
right and so what is what is the pain
that's there pain in the perception or
imagination of being wrongly slighted
being treated in a way that you think is
is wrong and then there's a pleasure in
imagining or carrying out retribution
you can be like oh I can't wait to get
that son of a [__] you know and then
the desire for apparent retribution
desire to make the other person suffer
in return and
interestingly Aristotle is not just
going to say yeah this is this is what
happens we we lose our our self-control
and it's because of these
factors Aristotle actually thinks that
losing your control due to anger is
morally better or at least less shameful
than losing control in general and why
so here's where we learn something
really important about
anger um anger as he says is like a
hasty servant that listens to some of
the instructions and then goes rushes
off and does what it thinks it's
supposed to do without actually paying
close attention and he says anger syes
it reasons uh Soden is is the word
that's being used there now don't think
about syllogisms you know with like two
premises and a conclusion it's not quite
that um uh rigid um but anger does
engage in reasoning processes but it
gets them kind of wrong it doesn't pay
attention to all of the
factors um he says that the acatic
person is controlled by their thum most
but also to some degree by reason but
the reasoning process there is distorted
it's it's a bit screwed up and then
that's one interesting thing so he says
you know it's more rational so that's
that's that's great um then it gives
three additional reasons for why accia
due to anger is morally better than um
accia due to desires for bodily
pleasures and he says it's more
excusable or forgivable to follow a
natural desire or reexes and um thumos
is more natural than
epithumia um so you know epithumia are
the desires for physical Pleasures uh
thumos he thinks is more at the core of
our Humanity than just being driven by
desire to eat have sex lay in the sun
stuff like that he also says uh
something that you might agree with uh
sonaka actually writes about this
specific specifically in his on anger
later on anger is more open it's more
publicly apparent fos above the board
right it's less given to plotting doing
things secretly when you get angry
you're you're letting people know
right um the desires for pleasure are
more secretive and so anger he says is
less unjust than you know these sneaky
people that are trying to get pleasure
and then in the rhetoric he provides
another U line of reasoning he says that
retribution against enemies is more just
than reconciling with them because
retaliation is just and therefore Noble
I I don't think we want to take this
quite so far as Aristotle does uh you
know there's debates about in the
rhetoric is he really like laying out
his moral theories or just saying here's
some arguments that you could make uh
but he does he does say that um and so
we can think about you
know
um how does anger actually affect our
our judgment and our reasoning and one
way that it does it is it makes us
narrow in we get too quick in reasoning
that an insult has been made we're less
likely to extend Good Will to others and
this can as he points out um in the
nican ethics as well as in the politics
this can be devastating for friendships
not just within families not just with
the the political Community but within
friendships as well if we uh lose that
you know good will to the other people
eoa um that is really quite uh you know
an obstacle to having good
friendships um so you know we can
ask and this is where we're going to
come back to the the various
rights um how does the nonv vicious non
acatic person the person who has
self-control how do they sometimes go
wrong with anger and how could practical
reasoning fit in with this practical
reasoning might be part of what is
screwing things up for us right if we
have the wrong sort of practical
reasoning um or it might be something
that gets things right so let's think
once again about these different um as
things should be or a right so right
person or wrong person right we can go
astray by thinking that somebody is is
uh doing something to us when they're
not doing something and we can go wrong
in thinking that the punishment or
retribution should be applied to this
person um we can also be frustrated when
somebody doesn't help us we take them as
being a jerk to us right when we when we
want help from them or they ignore us
right um sometimes people get angry at
other people preemptively over what
they're likely to do Aristotle says and
there's a reasoning process going on
there this person has said this thing
people who say these sorts of things are
likely to treat me this way therefore I
don't you know because I don't like that
I'm GNA get angry at them even though
maybe they're saying something
completely
different right grounds or wrong grounds
uh we infer that something constitutes
slighting it's not as if it's a natural
property of actions we have to read that
in you know and so you know one uh
particular Dy damic that Aristotle
talked about that we mentioned last time
is if somebody makes fun of something
that you care about especially if you're
insecure about that matter then you can
get angry at them because you feel like
you're being harmed like the thing that
you care about is being harmed when
really that's not the case at all I mean
if somebody says so I like heavy metal
right if somebody comes along and says
rat sucks twisted sister sucks Iron
Maiden sucks
how the hell does that affect those
bands it doesn't do anything to them and
it doesn't actually do anything to me
but we get angry about that that sort of
thing you know um how angry we get it's
not just a you know a knee-jerk reflex
reaction um the amount of anger that we
have we infer a kind of reasonable
proportionality in relation to the
perceived offense right so anger tends
to Blind us or make us bad judges of
this sort of measure this is why we
often get angrier than we we ought to
and Aristotle notes again back in the
rhetoric that there's Tendencies to get
angrier with certain people like our
friends right we think that we should be
treated better by our friends than by
other people and if they betray us we
get really really angry um how quickly
do we get angry you know should we let
some things go not interpret them as
sliding or should we apply a sort of
being able to brush things off give
people the benefit of the doubt right
those are matters of practical reasoning
um how long we should be
angry if we choose to dwell on Angry
thoughts you know reasonings or
arguments or fantasies that can keep us
angrier longer than we ought to be so
for example one of the common anger
treatments is you're angry count to 10
right or go take a walk now if you're
counting to 10 and you're like one that
son of a [__] made me angry two I need
to retaliate against them you're you're
gonna stay angry right that's not gonna
work you need to like clear your head if
you go for a walk and you think about
why you you hate this person and the
things that they do that's not going to
make you less angry right so that's
dwelling on Angry thoughts um we can
also ask if it's rational to hold
grudges long term you know um and this
is where anger gets really
dangerous anger can turn into hatred as
Aristotle recognizes it's actually one
of the causes of hatred and
hatred is not curable with time the way
that anger tends to be so we want to be
quite careful about that um how we
should act right there's practical
reasoning involved there as well a key
line of practical reasoning that aist
little talks about soand so slighted me
that's wrong I should seek retribution
and you know we could um engage in some
deliberation or some purpose of choice
we can ask ourselves is this something
good for me is this something good in
general um there's a tendency that we
have to focus too much on attaining
retribution how we can get it not enough
on the other relevant factors in the
situation like you're going to damage
your relationship with this person or
you're going to show yourself as being a
person with anger problems or you're
going to take take unnecessary physical
risks this is something people do all
the time or you might not even be able
to get that satisfaction you know if
you're going to try to hurt somebody and
they don't take it seriously you're
still going to be pissed off with them
right there's also a tendency on our
parts to
magnify the the sliding the thing that
somebody did that we don't like and to
seek to impose a
disproportionate uh retribution on them
as a result because we've we've already
you know sort of like old computer stuff
garbage in garbage out if we have
incorrect um uh reasoning or premises
about things we're going to get um
incorrect outputs as well so before we
go into the political or legal Dimension
uh let's take a few of these
questions so uh Robert says where does
comedy or wit or even the clown and the
hio have a place in this conversation he
doesn't have a place in this
conversation Aristotle's not mentioning
them I mean we could read
in that the person who is a
buffoon who is um joking all the time
might tick people off because you know
they think that things that shouldn't be
joked around about or being joked around
about or we could also get angry at the
person who's what Aristotle calls a
boore who doesn't like to to laugh with
the rest of us right and we could I mean
really we could get angry at
anybody who is perceived as being
vicious so you know for example when we
see somebody doing something cowardly we
can get angry at them for that right or
when we see something somebody doing
something rash we could a get angry at
them for that but we have to somehow
take it personally it's got to concern
us for us to get angry over it and so we
could ask ourselves what's our what's
our reasoning why why do we care so much
about you know what a clown does so that
we can get angry at them right I mean if
the clown is coming up to you and like
poking you in the eyes like The Three
Stooges that's a pretty straightforward
thing right but if you know so think
about how comedians make fun of
politicians right there are some people
with very very thin
skin um you know one of the motivators
for Donald Trump to like seriously run
for president was the fact that Barack
Obama made fun of him at the Press
Correspondence Dinner a long long time
ago and he Trump is a grudge holder he's
he's a perfect example of somebody who's
vicious with respect to to anger and
many other things too he's intemperate
he's unjust you know um and then you
know people can get angry at him quite
easily and you know so that that adds up
F how would you feel if you didn't eat
breakfast this morning it totally
depends I mean some bre some mornings I
don't eat breakfast other mornings I do
um if I need those those you know
calories and energy and stuff like that
and I'm not getting it we can often have
what we call being hry right Snickers
has made an entire set of commercials
about that where somebody's really mad
and mean and then they get a Snickers
bar and now they're back to being their
normal self and that would have to do
with what we talked about as the
physical somatic um dimension of anger
which we're not really going into here
um any other question oh let's let's
takes uh Selin's question at this point
in time how can we stay calm while
living in a developing country well I
mean the first thing to do would be look
at the other people who are living in a
developing country who are able to stay
calm many of which you encounter and say
how do they do it right it's not so much
about being in a developing country
because you can be here in the United
States where we have incredible
inequities and crazy disparities across
the line uh not just from state to state
but even within a municipality for
example here in Milwaukee we have some
of the poorest ZIP codes in the entire
nation right places where if you're born
there and you live there and go to
school there you're probably going to
have much worse outcomes than if you're
in some rich suburb or something like
that you know um this is not a uh just
developing country issue and and you
could say that part of it is thinking
about how you develop your own
self-control and you
know overcome the resentment and ranker
that's likely to arise you know all
right
[Music]
um Lal could anger be good Aristotle
thinks anger can be good and we just
talked about this at Great length
virtuous anger good anger right feeling
angry at the right time with the right
people to the right extent that that is
not just good that that's a virtue for
Aristotle this is where Aristotle is
going to differ from say the stoics you
know who think that anger is always bad
or Cicero Cicero also thinks that uh
White Tower social anger and outrage
have been the forces within Society all
along many forms of intolerances were
driven by a sense of
outrage anger was pretty much exploited
by leaders of the time yeah sure that
that's I mean that's why we need to be
virtuous with respect to anger um
Aristotle talks about this we're going
to get into this as we talk about the
political
Dimension um anger it's not the only
emotion hatred Envy lots of other
emotions can get appealed to as well in
similar ways but Anger from an
Aristotelian perspective can also be
good for mobilizing against Injustice
you know again big difference between
Aristotle and the stoics on on this
particular matter Aristotle thinks that
and so does Plato anger can be a useful
fuel but you gotta watch it just like
you would watch a fire in your campsite
so it doesn't start everything else on
fire um l call doesn't it contradict the
fact that the mean doesn't justify the
end there is no such fact I I don't know
where you got the idea that that's a
fact that you should believe in but it
sure as hell ain't um that's a saying
not a fact and it might be right or it
might be wrong and it depends on what
mean we're talking talking about what
end we're talking about you can't
generalize in that way right and the
mean here that we're talking about is
the middle position not the mean that
leads to an end right those are two
different senses of mean so you want to
be really really careful about your
vocabulary when it comes to that so all
right any other questions before we go
on to talking about the political
Dimensions legal Dimensions as well
of of
anger I'll get a little
drink because there there's
really uh T can we practice up to the
point that we have no anger at
all um uh I mean theoretically sure but
that would be foolish from an
Aristotelian perspective as we've
already explained because Aristotle
thinks there are situations in which you
need to get angry but if you want to try
to do this thing that almost no human
has ever pulled off more power to you
you even the stoics get angry uh on
occasion right
um all right so let's go on and talk
about the political ramifications of
anger and there's really um three that
that are important in the politics and
and one of these is in book five so
there's this term called stasis and
that's what book five is really about
stasis gets translated sometimes as
Revolution but that's not a good
translation for it social Discord social
breakdown is a better way of
understanding it it's when you have
factions that's another way of
translating factionalization factions
within society that are essentially
fighting with each other within the
society trying to dominate trying to
push their competitors out very often
saying bad things about each other um
and so Aristotle sees this as a big
problem in Greek city states and it's a
it's a big problem throughout human
history whether we're in city states or
nations or pick whatever I mean it can
happen within other organizations like a
company so um it doesn't happen just
because of like distinctively political
factors or Dynamics it's also because
all these things interpenetrate with
each other so one one that leads to this
in politics book one Aristotle talks
about how Being Human and having logos
which means both speech and
rationality allows us to have perception
and communication and sharing in
different values like the just and the
unjust or the noble and the Bas or the
good and the bad or the useful and the
harmful but we also disagree about these
and those disagreements what actually is
the right thing to do oh this is the
right thing no no this is the right
thing these can easily generate lots of
lasting conflict we also these
disagreements tend to happen in terms of
justice and equality and
fairness um in book five where he's
talking about stais Aristotle says that
it takes place because of equality and
inequality and disagreements about how
these are understood so you know rich
people tend to think that they're
entitled to the riches that they have
and that they're better than other
people this is a common Dynamic
Aristotle actually thinks you got to
really reign in the rich because they
tend to be um you know they tend to be
as we say uh here in America they get
too Bri big for their britches right and
they they act like jerks um Ordinary
People the the commoners the the many
tend to think that everybody should be
on the same level and they're Aristotle
says they're both right and they're both
wrong they're both wrong because take an
absolute
position um which is only qualifi true
they all make contributions to society
but they are not the central people uh
so that's very common people have
differing conceptions of what's right
and wrong what's just unjust fair you
know Equitable and then there's also the
desires for gain or profit people are
motivated to compete or honor and then
their opposites um and it's not just
about them it's also about their friends
and family and Associates and things
they identify with and so Aristotle
looks at the causes of stasis what what
actually leads to this so one of these
is what we call outrage or insolence
hubis fear is another major factor uh
superiority or predominance uh hoop in
in
Greek um contempt
katronis proportionate growth of a part
of the political
Community um Intrigue right people doing
uh things in back room deals sliding ol
legoria pettiness microtas mean you know
being being kind of
a skin flant or stuff like that and then
disim similarity now you notice that
when you look at these
um the you know a number of these are
actually the way anger Works contempt uh
hubis those are two forms of olor
sliding right so anger plays a
significant role within how stasis
actually works people get angry with
each other over this and then they're
likely to retaliate against each other
or to try to get each other things like
that um so you know the passions play a
central role in Social break
and uh you know hatred also plays a
major role as well and what are the
causes of hatred well one of these is
also a cause of anger spitefulness doing
things to screw with people just to
screw with them
um diabo slander you know saying bad
things about people which were likely to
do when we're angry and then the other
cause of hatred anger order gay right so
anger along with hatred along with fear
along with a couple other you know
desire and stuff like that plays a
really significant role in how things
break down for uh societies for
communities for
organizations uh even Fear Can involve
anger and hatred because what are we
afraid of in our
society uh Aristotle says even the signs
of um certain things are fearful things
and what are those things other people
being angry other people having hatred
if we if we think that other people want
to destroy us we fear them and then
we're likely to try to destroy them you
know or sideline them as a result when
we see people getting angry that can be
very scary too especially when the anger
is kind of out of control when we see
that it's vicious you know we think oh
what if that person gets angry at me or
angry at the people I care about right
so um these are these are quite
important factors so anger plays a major
role as does hatred as does fear in the
divisions within our society that can
lead to conflict that can lead
ultimately to social
breakdown um another really important
political Dimension or legal
Dimension what is anger really want it
wants to punish it wants to retaliate to
impose retribution on somebody so you
know when we perceive
wrongdoing um sliding unequal or too
slow Justice happening which is often
the case in our contemporary Justice um
uh you know situations let's call it
right we see people doing bad stuff and
they get a little fine um or they
nothing really happens to them that
pisses us off that that makes people
angry that can contribute to stasis but
that can also contribute to wanting to
see somebody punished right and if we're
vicious with respect to anger we might
be like I don't care who gets punished I
just want to see somebody pay for this
you know well that that can be a
significant problem Aristotle will at a
couple different places in the politics
and the rhetoric and the nicc ethics he
makes distinctions about how we should
look at people's wrong actions how you
know actions that are damaging to other
people and there's a Continuum there's
AA which is sort of we translated as
mischance the person didn't know that
this thing was going to happen at all
and it's just an unfortunate accident
but they're you know to some degree part
of the causality so they're they're
responsible to some degree but we we
shouldn't really get angry at them we
should actually feel pity for them more
than anything else then we have hamara
and this is translated quite often as
error or sin
or you know doing something wrong but
you know not doing something wrong
because we actively chose to do it but
because it's not just an accident now we
played a bigger role in it and it might
come from us being angry and then you
know revealing a secret that we
shouldn't have right or doing something
that that we we shouldn't um and that
can be forgiven but now we should also
be more careful about that and then we
have two other things somebody can
commit uh a wrong act something that is
actually morally
wrong and uh do so knowing that they're
they're doing it but you know maybe out
of a cossia right they get angry and
they um they lose their temper and they
swear at somebody right they they maybe
disparage their character or they they
lose their temper they punch somebody
right but that's not the way that they
act all the time they were being
provoked or things were really too much
for them right it's still a wrong action
right and it still has to be addressed
but it's not coming from Vice it's
coming from some some other lesser moral
failure and then we've got actions that
come from Vice and this is where we can
talk about the people who are vicious
with respect to anger right those who
typically are abusive right or those who
hold grudges for a long time and then
they finally get their revenge on
somebody and it screws things up for
everybody um that may be an you know
adikia an injustice that is committed
from the vice of Injustice and Aristotle
actually talks about uh in book five of
the nicam mcain ethics justice as
complete virtue and he uses as examples
of you know what this entails that the
law tell us not to hit each other or to
use abusive language that's with respect
to anger right so you know thinking
about the modalities of of wrongdoing
and how we should punish it and how
angry we should get at these people
another important political or legal
Dimension and then finally uh this is
kind of leading us into the fourth uh
dimension in politics book s Aristotle
talks about as I mention
before um the Greeks are the best people
according to Aristotle everybody else
are barbarians of one form or another
and uh in order to be the best kind of
people you need to have two things going
for you you need to be intelligent right
you have to have your dianoia your your
intellect going full uh full bore and
you also need to have
thumos uh working for you the part of us
that that gets angry or the dimension of
us that gets angry you need to be tho
ades right of the sort of people that
that are are angry like that and
um you
know the Greeks According to Aristotle
so we've got like a big picture and then
a little picture Greeks are right in the
middle and they are both intelligent and
thoes now not all the Greeks of course
because we have slaves and we have women
and we have all this this other stuff
going on at the same time right
um but we we at least do have
um uh that going for them now the people
to the South what we call geographic
determinism right the people to the
South like Egyptians and Phoenicians and
they're they're very interested in trade
and and motivated by their desires but
they don't have much thumos that's why
they're not very good Fighters and um
you know they're not you know they're
enterprising in terms of Commerce but
not in terms of noble things right and
now is is this true no I mean clearly
not right if we know much about ancient
history but Aristotle is indulging
himself in this thing that a lot of
Greeks would do as a matter of fact lots
of cultures do this sort of thing to the
north we have people like the Kelts you
know the the Germans aren't even really
on the horizon for for the ancient
Greeks they'll come in later on the
Kelts are the bad asses of the time as
are the cians and these people have too
much through most they love to fight all
the time right they're not that bright
um not like the Greeks um so you know
the Greeks are the ones right in The
Sweet Spot we could say and so you know
having the right amount of like
competitiveness anger that's viewed as
something important for societies and
and uh peoples for for
Aristotle he also says something really
interesting about this the capacity to
command to to rule over over other
people and the Love For Freedom he says
both of these stem from thumos again
that's why the Egyptians are you know so
willing to accept the tyranny of other
people you know they just want a nice
Easy Life they're not interested in
Freedom or running the show you know and
then the Northerners who get a little
bit too much of that thumos well they
love freedom you know perhaps too much
to to where it keeps them from being
able to work with each other and they
all want to be in charge right whereas
the Greeks again are in the the nice
sweet spot now of course Aristotle says
once we get to the Greeks like some
cities are more this way some cities are
more this way right uh and is is any of
this really that plausible I I would say
it's it's far too General but it's an
interesting point of view that he he
lays out and I think that this idea for
Aristotle that that the ability to
command other people and the love of
Elia Freedom both being connected
closely with thumos this is very
interesting and this kind of goes back
to Plato as well that that you know
spirited part of the Soul thumos plays a
important role with that uh I I'll
answer some questions in just a minute
but I do want to say one other thing
Aristotle as I mentioned
before um in in the Nic ethics in book
three he tells us that there in addition
to actual courage there's things that
look like courage but are actually not
and one of these is the thumos that we
might act upon and
interestingly the example that he gives
is of wild beasts protecting their
children they're doing so from a sort of
instinct and a spirited part of their
soul
even animals that we don't usually
associate with anger or or thumos like
lions will do so um when we threaten
their children quite often and Aristotle
takes this as um providing a certain
kind of ability to to fight back right
so when there when threats are
perceived that is often when not only
animals but us rational animals will get
angry and it's and that is a uh less you
know deliberate thought out response
it's more
instinctual um and so that's that's an
important dim menion as well so soin
says uh since I live in Turkey it's hard
for students to even survive that's why
I was curious to know how to stay calm
well that's that's I mean you don't
necessarily have to stay calm maybe it
makes sense to get angry about that but
you know angry with the right people um
it's not like you know um some other
poor person on the street who's the
should be the target of that it's
probably you know um the regime or the
the people who are exploiting uh other
people Jason says can you speak to the
positive parts of anger well we've done
that quite a lot in his Aristotle thinks
that anger is uh we can have be we can
be virtuous with respect to it we've
talked about all the different ways that
works today any sign of anger is viewed
as bad well that's not true today
signs of anger are viewed as bad by some
people in some contexts and it's the
opposite in other contexts so we can't
make sweeping statements like that like
any sign of anger is viewed as as bad um
and I I wouldn't even say we have a
heavy aversion to it as a society we're
actually a very angry
Society uh at least here in America and
uh in the West in general there are
probably lots and lots of people who are
indulging their anger there are certain
contexts where um people can be very
controlling about that but those are by
far not the norm everywhere right I
think there's I think you know going
back to Aristotle we in the present are
probably in situations where people tend
to be more
vicious in terms of exess with respect
to anger and unfortunately we don't get
a lot of good guid
or education or Council or formation
with respect anger we just say don't be
angry right but that doesn't help people
not to be angry we need to figure out
when we get angry uh an Aristotelian
would say well we need to figure out why
we're having this response what thoughts
are built into this what common
psychological Dynamics are at play in my
head or the head of the person that I
see who's getting angry right this is
where philosophy ancient philosophy in
particular but also medieval and early
modern philosophy and literature can be
incredibly helpful and that's one of the
reasons I've I've been doing these
sessions because I think that there is a
lot of not just wisdom in general but
useful practical advice
exercises considerations that we can
find if we actually go back and study
these ancient authors I know that for
myself as somebody who struggled greatly
with
anger I benefited just as much from
Reading
Aristotle and Plato and Plutarch as I
did from reading the stoics
so
um White Tower says could this virtuous
anger be interpreted as a voluntary act
on behalf of invisible auxiliaries so as
to protect the innocent citizens within
a society I mean I guess it could but I
don't see why you need
to um I the idea of invisible
auxiliaries I I don't know that that
makes much
sense um you know the auxiliaries
they're in Plato's Republic that's not
something that we use as a category in
our own not Plato's Republic all all the
time um I mean virtuous anger virtuous
anger is not a voluntary Act it involves
voluntary acts but it's it's something
that's rooted in your character so it's
not just a act it is to have a virtue is
not a single act it is a pattern of
behavior that has to do with developing
habits uh senin did Aristotle write
anything about women's anger and if he
did how is it different from Men's he
didn't um Aristotle doesn't say much
about women M much of the things that he
does say about women are kind of stupid
and and off based
um later authors sometimes will but it's
rare that you're going to find somebody
who's like well Women Are from Venus Men
Are from Mars there's none of that kind
of silly [__] in good ancient
philosophy it's more like a Continuum
and as a matter of fact like Plato for
example will say that women can be just
as thematic as men can be right that's
why um they can in in the Republic they
can be soldiers and police and stuff
like that um it's better to think of it
like a a Continuum where um and and it's
less about men and women it's more about
who has power and who doesn't have power
um women tend to be in in lower
positions they have power exercise them
some men not all men have you know more
privileged positions so they can express
anger more than than others but
Aristotle doesn't really explore that
not not an issue for for him I mean you
might think if you're thinking about
ancient literature and we're going to
talk about this in a couple
months think about the character Meda
who as you know we're going to
discuss very powerful uh
sorceress um she is sort of you know an
expression of anger you could say in the
uh greatest extent and sort of a
cautionary
tale um
you know about about women's anger uh
and what it could be about Zachary my
mother my grandmother's a Conservative
Christian she hates the world since she
things are getting morally worse her
metaphysical worldview affects her
decisionmaking how to deal with
irrational people uh you can't really I
mean if if things are really that bad
you're probably not GNA make much impact
on her you're not going to change her
mind um she's probably pretty set in her
ways and she's getting these messages
reinforced by watching Fox News or going
to church and hearing sermons about that
or whatever right um all you can do is
uh put that aside and decide whether you
want to have a good relationship with
her that's not based on her being pissed
off at the world you know I mean you can
still bake cookies or you know hang out
or do whatever you're gonna do right
that's that's about it I would say in a
situation like
that uh T how would you recommend
Plutarch books about anger well he's got
a book that's called uncontrolling anger
that is the place to start and if you do
start there you'll actually find that
I've got videos on it that could be uh
helpful for you he also discusses it you
know quite a bit in a number of the
other things that are part of what we
call the
moralia um anger it's less thematic
right but he'll talk about it in terms
of like uh the different parts of the
Soul he is a platonist so there is a
middle part that gets angry but is also
concerned with honor and and you know
freedom and things like that um and just
you know where you see the books where
he's talking about virtue that's the
places to go I would say um James Peach
can anger be good yes we've already
discussed that at Great length here um
as a source of motivation yes we've
already talked about that at Great
length here in in this session Elliot uh
environmentalists are similar to conern
consa ises that both think things are
worse than the average person uh I'd
avoid making super
sweeping generalizations like that
there's all different kinds of
environmentalists there's all different
kinds of conservatives some
conservatives think that things are
super awesome because we live in a
capitalist economy you know that's
chugging along I I'd avoid that kind of
overgeneralization because it's not it's
not helpful you know um and it's you
know if that's the way you think about
things that's going to get you in lots
of mistaken positions yourself and with
respect to anger you know one of the
ways that we screw ourselves up is by
feeding in wrong information into our
our heads about these these sorts of
things any other questions comments uh
we're going on close to 90 minutes here
and I've got another event I have to do
at the top of the hour but I can take
some more questions comments I I will
say too while people are uh writing them
so we've got more sessions to come we're
going to be doing another uh excursus
into uh Greek poetry you know we did
Homer and hassad we're going to be doing
ais's or esta in which anger plays a
major role those are three plays we're
going to be doing
um uh sopic um Ajax and ureides Meda two
plays where anger plays a really major
role and look at the characters so Ajax
is T ticked off at uus and meda's ticked
off at a jerk husband Jason right and
what do they do how do they handle this
um and then we're also gonna look at
epicurian positions on anger and we're
gonna by the end of the year we're going
to get to senica's book on anger which I
often teach in its entirety in my
classes that that deal with anger so any
any other questions
comments we're finishing up with
Aristotle at this point which is not to
say that we'll never come back to him
but um you know we're making some slow
steady
progress uh through this this uh
incredibly complex and Rich literature
out there dealing with this
emotion Zachary do you think it's
possible through practice to become
imper impervious to
insults uh yeah I mean I wouldn't frame
it as impervious I would rather I mean
if if you want to get on the way to that
I would get rid of that vocabulary and
and uh make it less you know
perfectionist and say is it possible
through practice to learn how to deal
with insults well so that you don't do
stupid things and respond
inappropriately sure I mean that's what
Aristotle uh talks about as as The
Virtuous position and we can think about
how we actually get there you know and
we can draw upon
multiple traditions and schools and
philosophers to do that um sellin oh
you're you're very welcome yeah um we'll
do more of these uh usually it's third
uh Saturday of the month but I got sick
this uh this month and had to move all
my events forward uh a ways um in
October it'll probably be later because
I think the third Saturday I am speaking
at the annual stoicon conference the big
International uh conference and uh
that'll be a lot of fun as well so all
right well I don't see any other
questions or comments so uh good to talk
with all of you and I hope you'll um you
know show up for the the other ones
there's lots that we can learn from
these Greek tragedy from other Greek
philosophers and I mean think about it
is like putting together a toolbox for
understanding and dealing with with
anger um it's nice to have a lot of
tools in the toolbox rather than just
one wrench and one screwdriver and one
hammer so all right I will see all of
you uh somewhere else in the ether have
a great you know for in Turkey have a
great evening I know it's pretty late
there uh same thing with Mark and South
Africa uh those who are you know closer
to here have a great
afternoon uh have a great morning for
some of you and I will see you down the
line